this video was made possible by nordvpn
go to nordvpn.com forward slash vpen and
get a two-year plan with a huge discount
plus four months free more on this in a
moment
[Applause]
[Music]
maximum tension here on visualpolitik we
have already told you how relations
between Washington and Riyadh are not
exactly going smoothly in fact they have
been in the doldrums for years and the
truth is that things are getting worse
and worse the old Alliance the old
partnership the special relationship
between Riyadh and Washington is
becoming a thing of the past and you
know why in a way this chart illustrates
why perfectly we've talked about this
many times for years Washington
guaranteed the security of the House of
sound the Saudi Royal House in exchange
for the country's abundant supply of oil
to the World Market and to Wall Street
with the Petro dollars generated by the
business it was something of a marriage
of pure convenience
no Mutual defense treaty or pact unites
has ever United the United States with
Saudi Arabia but despite this everyone
was utterly convinced that if the house
of Saud had run into any trouble the
United States would have rushed to its
Aid even if that would have meant using
all its military muscle not to mention
the thousands of U.S military
Consultants who trained and in practice
supported the Saudi military
however the fracking Revolution changed
absolutely everything suddenly the
United States became almost
self-sufficient in terms of oil
consumption and from that point on you
could say that the US began to see the
Middle East through different eyes and
naturally then came the divorce but wait
a minute because we've already covered
this in a past video that I'll link for
you in the description so the question
is why are we once again talking about
Saudi Arabia and the United States here
on visualpolitik
well basically because on the 5th of
October the Arab Oil Kings turned a deaf
ear to repeated requests from the White
House and announced an energy and
political Bond OPEC plus adds to biggest
oil production cuts and start of
pandemic moved to reduce daily output by
2 million barrels is likely to boost
prices and help Moscow and here we have
to highlight several key points on the
one hand the energy crisis and the halt
in oil and gas trade with Russia have
made the Persian Gulf once again an
indispensable supplier for the West for
example European Imports of gas and oil
from the Gulf have risen from around 10
to more than 20 percent in less than a
year that is they have doubled in just a
few months and that gives the shakes
enormous markets power the Petro
monarchies know this and now they want
to take advantage of it right now
everybody needs oil from the Gulf
everybody needs Saudi Arabia and the UAE
some people in Washington definitely
don't realize that there is a new Gulf
and that we don't take orders from
Washington anymore Abdul kalek Abdullah
professor of emirati politics and
visualpolitik viewers this is no trivia
your matter
money is pouring into the Persian Gulf
we're talking about hundreds of billions
of extra dollars specifically the IMF is
talking about a revenue windfall for the
Middle East and Central Asian exporters
of 320 billion dollars keep in mind that
that figure is just for 2022 and while
the shakes bet on containing oil price
increases in the past in order to punish
fracking producers now things seem
completely different let's just say that
the shakes want above all to replenish
the Royal coffers as quickly as possible
and that is exactly what they are doing
and also while they want to keep the
price of a barrel of Brent above 100 now
the point is that this money grab is not
the only geo-economic and political
consequence there is another one that
has to do directly with Moscow and
that's because the measure approved by
OPEC plus to cut World crude oil
production by 2 million barrels is a
real boost for the Kremlin just when the
West is on the verge of approving its
price cap on Russian oil and as we shall
see this has not gone unnoticed so the
question is are the shakes carrying out
a gigantic antic bailout for Russia well
listen up
but before we go any further let me tell
you about one of the most common cyber
security threats malware have you ever
heard of worms Trojans unless you live
on Mars I'm sure you have along with
viruses they are different types of
malware it typically steals data or
destroys it it could be an exe file run
in the background as legitimate software
or even affect other devices on your
local network and how can we catch it
well it could be transmitted over email
attachments software downloads or
operating system vulnerabilities and
most important of all how can we avoid
getting infected well you should keep
your system updated at all times your PC
Mobile phone router be cautious of
unknown email senders do not search
download or install any software from
dodgy websites as those are the main
source of malware and of course you can
use the nordvpn threat protection
feature to stay protected against
malicious files in addition to improving
your protection against phishing with
nordvpn you can surf Without Borders
choosing from over 5400 Ultra fast
servers from 59 countries around world
what's more you can use it on up to six
devices on every major platform Windows
Android iOS Mac OS Linux so don't wait
any longer go to nordvpn.com forward
slash vpen and get a two-year plan with
a huge discount plus four months free
and remember that you've got 30 days to
change your mind no strings attached and
now let's get back to the video
storm in Washington
[Music]
in Washington and particularly in the
white house it is very clear the Saudis
were the main culprits behind opec's
decision to cut oil production and the
fact that they did so just before the
midterm elections in the United States
and just when Putin's regime was having
the worst time in the Ukrainian war is
something they consider almost like
blackmail which basically didn't
surprise anyone you see during the
election campaign Joe Biden said that
Saudi Arabia was a pariah country and
that he would treat it as such from the
Oval Office this was the current
president's response to the brutal
murder of journalist Jamal khashoggi
however the Russian invasion of Ukraine
forced him to bite the bullet the West
suddenly needed to find Alternatives in
order to punish the Kremlin by cutting
off oil purchases but that was not so
simple after years of under investment
in the industry the oil and gas market
was terribly strained so the US
president and many other International
leaders had set out to find alternative
sources along the way Washington was
even willing to reach out to countries
such as Iran and Venezuela with pretty
dismal results so far by the way
[Music]
the fact is that the major golf
producers have once again become the key
players in this whole political energy
Saga and so in mid-july Joe Biden
himself invited Muhammad bin Salman in
Saudi Arabia it was not the friendliest
and warmest meeting in the world but as
a gesture it marked a turning point the
White House was willing to restart
relations with Riyadh if Riyadh would
actively join the grand International
Coalition against Russia or at least
take steps to cool oil prices and thus
some of the inflationary pressures that
are punishing half of the world so
severely
however just two and a half months after
the visit what almost everyone had
already suspected was confirmed that the
trip was a complete failure far from
announcing an increase in production
OPEC plus led by Saudi Arabia and Russia
itself had announced the opposite and
believe me that has unleashed the wrath
of Washington especially when only five
days before the announcement of the
measure envoys from the White House
traveled to Riyadh to ask the government
of Muhammad bin Salman not to do so but
it was all in vain so naturally
reactions were not long coming
[Music]
foreign
Senators including Robert Menendez the
chairman of the powerful Senate Foreign
Relations Committee have already called
for a freeze on all cooperation with
Saudi Arabia including military
cooperation in addition several senators
and congressmen both Democrats and
Republicans have already announced their
determination to push for new
legislation to suspend arms sales to the
Arab country and now the possibility is
even on the table that both the White
House and Congress itself May reactivate
the so-called no-pec Bill a bill that
seeks to prosecute punish and hold
accountable oil companies owned by
governments that are part of an oil
cartel without digging too deep this
would be the case of a ramco the
all-powerful Saudi oil company
the White House itself now appears ready
not only to change its foreign policy
regarding the gulf but also its own
energy policy for the United States if
the Biden Administration has so far
prioritized energy transition that could
be changing completely so to be clear
fracking is back in Vogue we're going to
work with our U.S allies to increase
production and make sure we have
sufficient refining capacity Amos
hochstein energy advisor to Joe Biden be
that as it may if one thing is crystal
clear it is that the OPEC plus decision
will mean more pain for Western
economies and particularly for Old
Europe which to tell the truth has not
been at its best lately
[Music]
however this is not even the most
negative aspect the most worrying thing
is that cutting production just when
Russia is having the worst time in the
Ukrainian war and on the brink of winter
seems to be a clear Lifeline for
Vladimir Putin's regime and a pressure
measure against the west and that makes
it worse much worse what Saudi Arabia
did to help Putin continue to wage his
despicable and vicious war against
Ukraine will long be remembered by
Americans Chuck Schumer Democratic
politician and Senate Majority Leader we
see no reason why American troops and
contractors should continue to provide
this service to countries that are
actively working against us if Saudi
Arabia and the UAE want to help Putin
they should look to him for their
defense statement of house Democrats Tom
malinowinski Sean Caston and Susan Wilde
so that begs the question is OPEC really
supporting Putin's Russia listen up
the Bears embrace
in Vienna at the OPEC plus meeting that
decided on the production cut there were
two major players Saudi energy Minister
abdulaziz bin Salman and Vladimir
Putin's Deputy Prime Minister Alexander
Novak a guy who just days before had
been sanctioned by the United States the
presence of the Russian Deputy Prime
Minister under U.S sanctions to discuss
tightening of oil supply heading into a
winter in which Russia has already
weaponized its gas exports to Europe
sends a clear message Roger daiwan
Analyst at s p global commodity Insight
let's be clear the petrol monarchies
insist that cutting production is not a
political issue it's just business
however one thing is very clear the Gulf
States have not condemned the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and have not
supported any of the sanctions and now
they have not listened to their former
U.S Ally either and here is the very
important point that we cannot Overlook
by far the country that has benefited
the most from the production Cuts is
precisely Putin's Russia why well let me
explain
[Music]
unlike Saudi Arabia the United Arab
Emirates Iraq or Kuwait Russian oil
extraction costs are much higher in fact
it is estimated that on average they are
double those of Saudi Arabia we're
talking about more than 40 dollars per
barrel but that's not all International
sanctions and a lack of buyers have
meant that Russia is selling its oil to
countries such as India and China at
discounts of up to 35 off the global
quoted price what's more as you can see
on the screen redirecting Russian oil
sales to markets as far away from
production sources as China or India
also implies much longer lead times and
therefore higher logistical costs to
break it down 40 extraction costs 35
trade discount and higher logistic costs
means that selling below 80 per barrel
and Russia virtually stops making money
on its crude exports so you can guess
what price a barrel of rent was just
before the announcement of the
production cut exactly it was touching
the 80 barrier you see the sharp
economic slowdown in China and in
general the worsening performance of
Western economies caused the price of
oil to Fall by nearly 20 percent from a
hundred dollars in July 2022 to 80 at
the end of September and that was a
terrible blow precisely for Russia
however now with the production cutback
things are changing
[Music]
yes Saudi Arabia will earn more money
per barrel but it will also extract and
sell fewer barrels the difference will
be positive but not that big for Russia
on the other hand the increase in oil
prices make an enormous difference below
80 a barrel the Kremlin earns
practically nothing and let's not forget
that in 2021 oil profits covered 45 of
all Russian public spending in other
words in order to poke Washington in the
eye to reinforce the unity and position
of OPEC plus as the cartel that sets the
international price of crude oil and to
benefit from the war this time the gulf
petrol monarchies have decided at least
for now to clearly align themselves with
Moscow and it's not just Saudi Arabia
the United Arab Emirates for example has
also happily seconded the production cut
perhaps it has something to do with
Dubai becoming the New Mecca the new
fashionable refuge for Russian oligarchs
Russians flee to Dubai ticket prices
soared to five thousand dollars as
tensions rise over a nuclear threat
since the start of the war in Ukraine
Russians and particularly Russian
millionaires have rushed to Dubai to buy
property setup business and secure their
fortunes for example in the UAE buying a
property valued at 750 000 Dirhams
roughly 204 000 at the current exchange
rate assures you three years of
residence and of course larger
Investments can secure you much longer
and although things are not as easy as
they used to be for the Russians
especially when it comes to financial
operations they are managing to use
Dubai as one of their new bases of
operations this of course is
contributing to a whole new golden age
for the city you know the old story
business is business but wait a minute
because this time the Arabs might not do
so well
the game
one of the great mistakes that dictators
and autocrats tend to make is to always
overestimate the cards that they are
holding as they tend to be surrounded by
psychophants and live in a kind of
bubble where their word is law they
often end up risking more than they
should this is exactly what happened to
dictators like Saddam Hussein Muammar
Gaddafi or more recently to Vladimir
Putin himself with the invasion of
Ukraine now something very similar could
happen to the Saudi leader Muhammad bin
Salman why well because this latest move
makes it very clear that Saudi Arabia is
no longer in any way a reliable partner
for the West
oil production in the United States and
the rest of the world is almost certain
to increase strongly over the next few
years while the development of
alternative energies including nuclear
power will also accelerate in other
words riyadh's move may end up reducing
the country's future profits at the same
time military cooperation with the
United States is essential for the
kingdom not only to be able to access
the latest equipment and defend itself
in the event of the conflict with a
country like Iran but also in order to
maintain the thousands of jobs that have
been created in the country
and of course if the Ukrainian War has
made anything clear it is that when it
comes to Advanced Equipment there is no
alternative to Western and particularly
U.S supplies above all Saudi Arabia has
been telling us for years that it is
going to invest gigantic amounts of
money to diversify its economy however
for that to really happen it needs to
cooperate commercially with the
wealthiest countries in the world that
is with Western companies and measures
like this do not contribute in the least
to that goal in any case what is clear
is that the Petri monarchies have
challenged the North American Giant the
question is what do you think the United
States will do will Western countries be
able to avoid falling back under the
influence of the Arab countries do you
think that this measure is purely
commercial as the Saudis claim or on the
contrary is it a political move leave us
your impressions below and let's open up
a debate and of course if you found this
video interesting don't forget to like
And subscribe to visualpolitik if you
haven't already done so thank you so
very much for watching all the best see
you next time
[Music]